The question of how far
we can go when we enhance,
or adjust, or touch up an image
in science is a critical one.
You are all familiar,
I'm sure, with
the stunningly
beautiful Hubble images
published all over the world.
But most of the world is
not familiar with the fact
that the colors
we're seeing were
artificially created, decided
and implemented by humans.
You can read a
conversation I had
with some of these
researchers in American
Scientist, in the
resource section,
look for this thumbnail.
I think you'll find the
article interesting,
about the decisions the
researchers made about coloring
the detail of nebula.
So in essence, the
coloring, or enhancement,
was mostly done for the purpose
of communicating structure,
and I would say also for
helping bring attention
to these amazing images.
Now remember, these
pictures of the universe,
are representations, that
is re- presentations,
they are photographs
of that universe,
they are not the universe.
All the photographs
in this course,
and the ones you are
making and will make,
re- present various structures
and phenomena, in order
to communicate research.
You, the image maker,
has to make decisions
in order to make these re-
presentations, as I do.
Should I make an
image of this or that,
shall I compose it
this way or that?
When shall I set up my camera,
in the winter or in the summer?
At five minutes of the
phenomena, or three days later?
What tool shall I use,
should I use a scanner
or a stereo microscope?
What lighting set
up should I use?
What background is best?
So, in a way, the whole
process of photography
requires us to make decisions
about making adjustments,
for the purpose
of communication.
The question we
must ask ourselves
is, do any of these choices
misrepresent reality.
So that process of selecting
colors in the Eagle Nebula
is similar to my process when
I colored this image, which
was originally grayscale.
I made the image with electrons
on a scanning electron
microscope, an SEM.
We needed electrons
to see the nanowires,
they were too small
to use photons,
as we do in photography.
Once again, the purpose
here is to show more clearly
the structure.
The difference
between my adjustment
and the astronomers'
adjustment is
that the color choices of the
researchers in the article
were informed by
chemical characteristics
of the various
areas of the image.
My choices in this particular
case was purely aesthetic.
But first and foremost
with any work in science,
whenever we color any
SEM or other image,
we must always indicate
what we have done, period.
Somewhere near the image,
not on another page,
we have to dig deeply to
see what's going on here,
somewhere near the
image we must say,
"this image was color enhanced."
The subject of enhancement
is not discussed enough
in your training.
Many of you just assume that
certain adjustments can be made
in software on your pictures.
That is not the case.
I can't possibly go through
every example of adjustments
at this point, but
I'd like to encourage
you to start thinking about it,
from the very beginning when
capturing your
work, when you start
a particular investigation,
which you will be submitting
for a publication,
when you start
documenting the work as
evidence of your research.
Just as Important, I'm
encouraging you to have this
kind of conversation
with your colleagues,
to create a mindset in your
lab of do's and dont's.
We just don't talk
about it enough.
So let's even start
with these videos you've
been watching for our course.
I mentioned to you
in the welcome video
that I digitally cleaned
some of the images
that you're looking at.
The reason I gave you for
getting rid of the specks,
was so that you would
not be distracted
by imperfections in the various
samples that I photographed.
Well, that was a decision I
made for this particular purpose
for this course, to
teach you about process.
And most important is the
fact that I informed you
of my adjustment.
However, if you are submitting
an image for a published
figure to a journal, well
that's a whole different story.
I was privileged to have a long
conversation with a few editors
and the art director at Nature.
We discussed a number of
examples you'll be seeing here.
We talked about what is
permitted and what is not.
First, we concluded that
the rules for cover images
are different from
images in figures.
Nature regards cover submissions
more as illustration, or "art,"
and in that case,
one is permitted
to clean some specks and
distracting material,
and to add color for example,
if the image is initially
in black and white.
Here's a picture
I made, starting
with the unadjusted image
of the yeast colony,
and here I digitally
deleted the Petri dish,
because I wanted the viewer
to see the stunning morphology
of the colony.
The data in the image is the
morphology of the colony.
I'm not adjusting
that data, I am simply
removing the part of the
image that in my opinion
is unnecessary or distracting,
although not everybody agrees
with me.
Science did permit that
adjustment for the cover,
and once again I
described the adjustment
in the cover captions.
Here, I made this image
of a device on film,
so because the lighting of
the lab created a green cast,
it's how the film
read the scene.
My adjustment of
the color was trying
to get the image to
what my eyes saw,
and in my opinion is acceptable.
And this one taken under
a stereo microscope,
we see an artifact of
the process, a reflection
of the lens on the wafer.
So here I remove the reflection,
again always indicating
what I've done.
In this one, which you've
seen before, I first
use the stereo microscope,
but because with this tool
I didn't have control over
the direction of the light,
we're seeing all
sorts of distractions.
In the second image, which I
made with a camera and a lens,
the image is cleaner.
I did not digitally
clean the specks ,
it just looked better with this
equipment and this lighting.
Or let's take this
device one step further,
where I made this detail
with a microscope.
Using a technique
in microscopy called
Nomarski Differential
Contrast, which
emphasizes surface
structure, based
on the index of refraction.
That's why you're
seeing all these colors.
So all of these decisions
address which tool shall
I use, basically adjusting my
point of view, which translates
into adjusting the final image.
This one is a more
complicated question,
which the editors and
I discussed at length.
In effect, we started
having a conversation
about what is reality, which is
a subject I promise we're not
going to pursue here,
but in essence this
is a question that
should be somewhere
in the back of your thinking.
After all, you are making
re- presentations of reality,
aren't you?
So here's the
image, which I hope
gets you to think a little bit.
These are rods, measuring about
two to three centimeters long,
all of which have absorbed
fluorescing material.
This is the image I captured
on film under UV light,
however my eye saw this
image with orange rods.
It turns out the film did not
capture the orange wavelength,
so I digitally adjusted
those rods that
were supposed to appear orange.
That adjustment was not
acceptable to the editors
it turns out.
In my opinion, the adjusted
image was closer to reality
than the unadjusted image.
What do you think?
And take this one, here
is the original image
of these amazing
Proteus colonies
growing in a Petri dish.
As it happens, the agar is
cracking in a few places.
I made the image for the book
On The Surface of Things,
the point was to show
how the colonies grow.
And I didn't want to
detract the reader
from the point of the image, so
I digitally deleted the cracks.
Now the Nature editors
all agree this would never
be accepted for a figure
in their journal, which
makes sense.
But what about a book for the
public, what do you think?
Here's an image from another
of my articles in American
Scientist.
Look for the thumbnail
again under the resources.
I very mistakenly deleted
a small speck in the middle
of the glowing circle here.
I did so after asking the
researcher if I could do so,
and he very politely
said it was fine,
but years later when
we discuss the article,
I realize that that
deletion was very improper.
It turns out that
that small speck
had an important effect on the
final outcome of the image.
I guess at the time he
was trying to be easy,
and the article was not part
of a journal submission.
But now, and we both agree,
the mistake was clearly mine.
I had no right to
adjust that image,
even after asking
for permission.
Here's that
adjustment, by the way,
you saw before, reverting
a grayscale image,
and the editors did
accept that at Nature.
Now how about this one?
It's true that these
are microscopic images,
and beyond the
realm of the course,
but I thought it
would be important
for you to think about it.
The researchers supplied me with
two of their original images.
The colored areas
gave highly detailed
morphological information
about the cell,
as specific quantum
dots attached
to specific structures.
When the dots are
excited with UV light
they fluoresce, and so
we see where they attach.
In standard views of
fluorescently labeled material,
the colored areas are set
against a black background.
I thought it would
be interesting
and maybe more
communicative to see
the information differently,
as long as I maintain
the integrity of the science.
So I inverted the two
images in Photoshop
to give a white background.
But because it was important
to keep the original colors
of the structures themselves,
I changed the colors back
to the red and green.
I then layered
both of the images
over a third image taken with
standard microscopy, again
supplied by the laboratory.
The three layered results
shows the same information
as the original separate
images, with the addition
of a sense of the whole.
I'm showing you where
the structures are,
I'm not quantifying the amount
of quantum dots present.
Another form of adjustment,
changing histograms,
can also be part of
our conversation.
Here's an old gel run
created a while ago,
when the runs were
still captured on film.
The point I want to make
here, it's still relevant.
So here I am zooming
into a portion,
after I change the
histogram for the whole run.
Now that's important, I
didn't take a portion.
In this one, I adjusted
the contrast even more,
and on this one even more,
to better see the bands.
Now what do you think about
this, is this permitted?
The editors at
Nature were initially
comfortable with
the enhancements,
since the adjustment
was universally
made to the entire image.
And later in the
conversation, they
emphasize the
requirement to indicate
how that image was enhanced.
OK, so what about this one?
The tank you're
looking at was used
to study sediment rates of sand.
And it was too large to
photograph in one image,
and so I made the
couple of images
and superimposed them
for a journal article.
You'll notice I stitch
the two images together,
showing the fact that
there are two images,
you're seeing the overlays.
I did the same for this image,
this time microscopic, again
since it wasn't possible to show
the whole device in one image.
And here again, I decided
to include the boundaries
to each image, letting
the viewer know
the full image is a collage.
And for this one, the
researcher made single SEMs
and used Microsoft software
to stitch the pieces together
for the article.
Here we cleaned it a
bit, what do you think?
Once again, I want
to say there are so
many possibilities
in this conversation,
but it's critical that you keep
all of these questions in mind
when you talk to each
other, and certainly
when you start thinking about
communicating your work.